How do I get the desire
to have discipline?
I keep getting asked
this type of question.
How do I get disciplined or how do I
want discipline or how do I maintain
discipline? And the answer,
it's, it's a simple answer,
but obviously it's not easy.
And there's all all kinds of little
tricks and methods that people talk about
and you know, they have
some merit, you know,
maybe they do work these,
these things, you know,
do the little things people
say and wake up early.
I say that and write things down and take
cold showers and to tell everyone what
you're going to do. So broadcast
it and make promises or,
or make bets with, with your friends of
something that you don't want to lose.
And those things, those
ideas, they're, they're cool.
I'm sure they're going to have some
impact and if they work for you, that's,
that's awesome. But,
but the fact of the matter is that the
reason discipline is hard to maintain is
because it is hard to maintain.
That's what makes
discipline hard. It's hard.
And if you hear me claim that
discipline is easy for me,
then straight up, that's
just my ego talking.
That's what that is because I'm
unfortunately just as human as everyone
else and it is a work to maintain the
discipline. That's what it
is. Work holding the line,
maintaining the standard,
giving no slack, none.
That's the discipline,
that's the discipline and it is hard.
And if there's one thing I would
say that does make it easier,
it's to envision what it
feels like when you're done,
what it feels like after you've worked
out or you've held the line on your food
intake or you've pushed through some
monotonous project that you have to do in
all those things. When
they're done, they feel good
and contrary to that,
invision what you will feel like later.
Do you let the discipline
slack, you know the feeling,
feeling weak and deed and you
know that you're falling behind.
So get to know those two different types
of feelings and ask yourself which one
you want to feel in 10 minutes
or in a half an hour. When,
when the thing is done, when
the discipline has blend,
implemented,
remember what that feels like,
and then remember that those
minutes and those hours,
they turn into weeks and months and years
and holding the line in those critical
minutes will put you in an infinitely
better place physically and mentally if
you maintain the discipline.
So work through the weakness,
fight through the
temptation. Hold the line,
hold the line, maintain the discipline.
It is not easy,
but it is worth it
because yes,
because discipline equals freedom.